herr blume olympiahalle hanau wird
rechter terror verharmlost der
mordanschlag an cdu politiker walter
lübke
der angriff auf eine synagoge in halle
jetzt elf tote in hanau darunter der
täter selber die frage wird rechter
terror verharmlost finde ich da schon
relativ absurd antwort ja in der tat
wenn das alles linke gewesen wären oder
wenn das alles islamisten gewesen wären
dann hätten wir schon dann hätten wir
hier wie in italien
gepanzerte fahrzeuge in den straßen und
überall standen polizisten mit
sturmgewehren dadurch dass das rechte
sind sagt man nur ja die idee erzählung
brauchen sie ich finde jetzt also ist ja
eine ernste sendung einem ernsten zu
einem ernsten sehr ernsten thema und da
will ich jetzt nicht gleich irgendwie
polemisch werden aber haben sie schlicht
das gefühl sie benutzen diesen anschlag
jetzt um endlich was behaupten zu können
was sie in keiner weise belegen können
natürlich gab es einen riesengroßen
aufruhr empörung trauer wut als
meinetwegen ein islamist so ewig lange
ist es noch nicht her so weit von hier
in berlin war es nicht weg in den
weihnachtsmarkt gefahren ist 2016
und natürlich wurde dann ganz viel über
islamismus gerät und man hat versucht
oder die ganzen behörde haben versucht
da mehr rein zu leuchten zu gucken was
passiert in moscheen z und genauso ist
es mit herrn luc gehen nach halle nach
hama und auch davor schon gewesen
ich glaube nicht dass hier irgendwas
verharmlost wird nach diesem anschlag
amoklauf attentat rechtsextremen
meinetwegen verwirrten card können wir
gleich noch dazu kommen ist jetzt die
gesamte politische elite dahin gefahren
hat sich solidarisch gezeigt hat dir
betroffenheit ausdruck verliehen ich
glaube diesen leuten ich glaube nicht
dass irgendjemand ein interesse hat das
zu verharmlosen
die verharmlosung besteht darin dass
jetzt auf dem jahrelang haben sie in den
raum gestellt ich habe gerade ist eine
stärkere gerade doch auf das was sie
gesagt haben die verharmlosung besteht
darin ich definiere ihnen jetzt warum
ich finde dass sich tatsächlich um eine
systematische verharmlosung handelt die
verharmlosung besteht darin dass wir
jeden dieser fälle immer als einzelfall
behandeln und dann auch immer gleich
sagen es ist ein einzeltäter ein
einzelfall und
umständlicher beatrix von storch aus
einem ganz anderen zusammenhang zu
zitieren nix hat mit nix zu tun das ist
hier aber meiner meinung nach und das da
ist offenbar ein lizenz zwischen uns
keine ahnung was ich nicht
meiner meinung nach gibt es eben schon
einen systematischen zusammenhang
zwischen diesen zahlen sie müssen sich
ja schon mal ein nein sie müssen sich
rein führen dass wir in den kommenden
neun monaten in den vergangenen neun
monaten sind insgesamt 13 leute
umgebracht worden von tätern mit rechtem
hintergrund lassen sie wie viel die
gesamte raf in ihrer ganzen geschichte
umgebracht hat weil wenn das so
weitergeht dann überholen die rechten
die raf noch in diesem jahr das ist
wirklich absolut aber ist das
interessant und der diskurs level ist
abstrus niedrig dafür was hier
eigentlich los ist in diesem land
ich weiß nicht ob wir nochmal so eine
panik brauchen die es rund um die raf
gegeben hat also ich weiß nicht ob die
der staat damals so smart so clever und
so gelassen vor allen dingen reagiert
hat wie er vielleicht hätte reagieren
sollen ist geschichtlich historische
betrachtung können wir auch ad acta
legen
aber das nochmals als einfach nochmal
einen zwischen gedanken dazu
die frage ist es eine rechte struktur im
sinne einer schwer vergleichbar aber
nehmen bis jetzt raf also gibt es eine
kommandozentrale gibt es aus läufe gibt
es die erste die zweite die dritte
generation da lautet die antwort bis
dato nein es gab die nsu das war eine
struktur die hat gemordet wie eine
struktur die hatte ein refugium pläne
hilfe helfer zuträger ich weiß nicht was
das war eine struktur viel zu spät
erkannt skandalös spät erkannt da war
zumindest was diesen fall angeht die
verfassungsschützer die polizei auf dem
rechten auge blind zu - haben sie es
nicht gesehen aber hier ergibt sich die
struktur an bei ihnen das heißt der
platz ist da aber es ist doch ich freue
mich dass ich schnell zum punkt es gibt
leute die diese struktur ist struktur
erst ein baader meinhoff sich
zusammensetzen und sagen das ist unser
nächstes anschlagsziel oder es struktur
wenn sie dann feststellen dass im
mordfall lübke die gleichen figuren
sozusagen im umfeld auftauchen wie schon
bei nsu wenn sie ihn feststellen dass
viele von diesen leuten bei anschlägen
die veranstalter waren auf den
demonstrationen rumgehen vielleicht
haben sie dann trotzdem auch eine
struktur nämlich sozusagen eine sub
struktur in der gesamten gesellschaft im
öffentlichen diskurses hatte das ist
doch das interessant
also wenn es danach für das aber kann
ist meinte ksc mit dem thema wenn es
helfer sind zuträger wie gesagt wenn es
da eine verbindung zwischen
protagonisten des einen anschlages und
des zweiten anschlags gibt dann bis
würde ich es strukturen denn was ich
nicht als struktur bezeichnet wurde und
was ich mir auch nicht anheften lassen
denn darum geht es doch jetzt auch wenn
mit uns nichts vormachen dieses ding ist
ein derartiger politischer vorgang dass
er natürlich politisiert wird und dann
bin ich teil des systems das diesen
anschlag möglich gemacht hat und nur
weil ich mich selber als mein ding
rechts oder konservativ bezeichnet weil
ich ab und zu als kritisches über
flüchtlinge gesagt habe bin ich für
bestimmte leute nicht ganz zufällig gehe
auf dem linken teil des spektrums des
politischen spektrums verortet stopp bin
ich bereits teil einer
erfüllungsgehilfen schafft die diese
daten ermöglicht und dagegen wehre ich
mich und das darum ist der begriff
struktur so wichtig weil er eben
inflationiert werden kann so wie sie es
eben zumindest dargestellt haben ja im
sinne von jeder der den diskurs rohr
gemacht hat in den letzten fünf jahren
der den diskurs vielleicht auch ein
stück politisch auf der skala nach
rechts verschoben hat ist teil dieses
problems
und das stimmt nicht ich glaube genau
andersrum aber es ist gerade am 14.2
der bundesweite razzia gegen ein rechtes
netzwerk teutonico bin mir gar nicht
sicher ob so viele zuseherinnen und
zuseher diesen begriff überhaupt schon
mal gehört haben toni co das war so zehn
leute die haben sich getroffen und haben
sogar irgendwie wir besorgen geld wir
sorgen waffen und du greift die moschee
an begreift die moschee an du greifst
die moschee an
obwohl die polizei glücklicherweise muss
man sagen auf solche leute dann eben
doch ein auge hat haben sie die einfach
hobbs genommen ja und die ist jetzt mal
gucken wie man die sozusagen anklagt ob
das eine terroristische vereinigung ist
oder nicht oder sollen ein ganz kurz mir
geht es um ein anderes mitglied sind was
an sich hat noch mal geguckt das waren
14 20 16 2 anne will thema politik in
krisen modus erhält das land zusammen
beim 19 21 berger thema machtkampf in
der cdu siebzehnter zweiter platz
bergwelt dem klimawandel
komisch das irgendwie das ausheben einer
rechten terror zelle
die geld gesammelt haben waffen kaufen
wollte um moscheen anzugreifen
keiner dieser talkshow zum thema wert
war ein bisschen ich kenne ich
verharmlosung
ich weiß dass das land das würde das
will ich in keinem fall sagen ich kann
nicht beurteilen
als erstes möchte ich keine kollegen
schelte betreiben dann hat mich dann
würde ich auch sagen dass sie das
gemacht haben sie wollen das nicht macht
nein zumindest birnbaum der sicheren
seite bleiben weil ich nicht so billig
machen möchtet überhaupt scheint
fraglich ist nicht so billig machen
möchte sie haben die bei der aufzählung
dessen was diese leute gemacht haben
nämlich vergessen dass der einer sich
dann hat nadine nennen lassen der andere
musste tor oder so ähnlich genannt
werden ich will das nicht damit nicht
noch einmal verharmlosen aber ich habe
dies als ich sie das gelesen habe was
das für leute waren die sich dahin
gesetzt haben uns zu zehnt schnell
beschlossen haben die weltherrschaft zu
übernehmen habe ich das auch nicht so
völlig ernst nehmen dann nämlich reichs
bürger die übrigens auch gerade haupt
genommen worden sind oder so was wie
combat 18 also eine echte rechtsextreme
sich verschworene struktur in sich
verschworene struktur die verboten und
ausgehoben worden ist vielleicht sogar
viel zu spät kann sein aber immerhin
nehme ich da viel ernster als eine
truppe wurde eine sich tor und der
andere ohne ihn nennt tut mir leid ist
vielleicht aus der ferne und moment
halbwissen betrachtet aber war so mein
gefühl
weshalb mir anders als ihnen nicht
aufgefallen ist dass das kein oder
negativ aufgefallen ist dass das kein
thema
unser tortoise zehn angriffe mindestens
auf moscheen im jahr 2019 unterziehen
das sind zwei bücher woche es ist mir
deshalb wichtig weil weil wir haben uns
das es so in einem ausmaß alltag
geworden bei uns dass das vollkommen
untergeht ich habe das auch mir war das
nicht klar ich habe es jetzt für diese
sendung recherchiert recherche hilft im
eröffnet übrigens auch manchmal dem
journalisten die augen mir war das nicht
klar dass wir pro woche zwei angriffe
auf moscheen haben in deutschland und
dann hätte und das alleine zeigt schon
dass wir den rechten terror verharmlosen
denn das wissen die alle realistisch
also ein angriff und sachbeschädigung da
führt wenn man das überhaupt vergleichen
möchte an so einem aus anlass eines
solchen ereignisses da führt dann was
sagt beschädigt und solche dinge
das linke spektrum mit diesen politisch
motivierten straftaten
wir sehen doch es geht aber um es geht
um muslime
ziel von von von rechts terroristischen
angriffen reagiert übrigens heißt das
jetzt ganz kurz es ist eben auch nicht
so dass dieser angriff uns allen gilt
das wird jetzt immer sagt ja sagen die
politiker dieser anstalt uns alle
er galt nicht ihnen und mir sondern der
gilt praktisch den muslimischen
mitbürger der in die shisha bar geht ja
aber es geht ja ja und natürlich geht
uns allen fühlen sie sich jetzt sicherer
ich fühle mich nicht sicherer weil ich
mich erstens frage was kommt da noch
alles wann wachen möglicher oder wann
gelingt es den sicherheitsbehörden
diese leute auszuheben weitere anschläge
dieser art zu verhindern kann man das
überhaupt männer natürlich betrifft mich
das in meinem alltag auch wenn ich nicht
der klassische kunde einer shisha bar ja
das glaube ich ihnen angst kann auch in
der sicherheits werden allein ist durch
ein gesamtheitliches thema weiß wie es
hier die verharmlosung ist doch nicht
das ich aber das ist doch gar nicht
sichern so gehörten feuerstein
unterstellen permanent der gesellschaft
den behörden ich weiß nicht was
verharmlosung und können es einfach
nicht belegen
ich weiß doch ich kann mein leben ich
habe darf ich nein ich glaube es hat
keinen sinn aus so einem anschlag auf so
einer maut serie muss man inzwischen ja
sagen weil mindestens drei fällen jetzt
noch mal zu versuchen bestimmte
politische äußerungen die sich die ihnen
vielleicht nicht gefallen die arbeit
immer noch rechts der mitte aber klar im
inneren des spektrums sind im grünen
bereich wenn man so will zu
diskriminieren und zu sagen das dürfte
nicht mehr sagen weil ihr macht euch
damit so ein helfern den erneuert sich
wenn in leipzig connewitz linke chaoten
sich mit polizisten prügeln ja was
schreibt dann die bild -zeitung
gewaltexzess in leipzig hauptstadt des
linksextremen terrors da sind die ganz
ganz schnell dabei mit dem wort terror
wenn linke chaoten polizisten verprügeln
und im zweifelsfall auch ordentlich eins
auf dem ihr zu bekommen dann sind wir
mit dem wort terror ganz ganz schnell
dabei und nur um das damit sie mir hier
nicht gleich irgendwie einen reinwürgen
ich verharmlose die gewalt von linken
chaoten gegenüber prinzessin beim 0
aber die waage als halb hamburg und ich
haben teile von hamburg wirklich in
flammen auf
hätten natürlich jederzeit auch jemand
um kommen können das macht das ja hier
kein stück besser
und natürlich ist das terror und sie
werden wir jetzt nicht anheften wer wann
zu erstes terror genannt hat natürlich
ist also recht sagt deshalb weil die
gleichsetzung von vorn von links extrem
und rechtsextrem die gleichsetzung von
linkspartei und afd
diese art von devils 2 bietet schon nein
das bietet schon sozusagen das ist schon
der weg irgendwie in dieser art von am
grund ja finde ich linksextreme und
rechtsextrem finde ich gleichermaßen
verachtenswerte weil es bei der maßen
gleichermaßen darauf zielt diese
gesellschaft zu verändern dieses
landsmännern er ob die linkspartei und
ard gleich setzen müssen damit man
länger drüber reden ich finde es gibt
gute gründe beide parteien nicht zu
wählen und dass sie deshalb gleich
gesetzt haben aber es komisch dass wir
gar keine linken toten haben in den
letzten jahren aber aber eine
behinderten seit dem jahr 1990 je nach
zehn ungefähr 200 tote die 210 welchen
dimensionen geht ja eigentlich unterwegs
sind die auf das konto rechter
rechtsextreme straftäter gehen
das müssen sie sich mal vorstellen ja
ich war also die zahlen offiziell soll
deutlich niedriger macht es auch nicht
wirklich besser
da ist die offizielle zahl der
bundesregierung zumindest 75 oder 76
dann will ich es gar nicht verschließt
gar nicht kleinreden aber hätten wir
diesen diskurs geführt bei der raf
also da war es eben dem terror von links
das macht es doch nicht besser oder
schlechter
es gibt auch keinen guten oder keine
halb schlimm oder ganz schlimmen terror
und andersrum wenn wir jetzt reden meint
wegen also nehmen sie an g20 ganz klar
linker protest wäre von rechten in der
reform auf die straße getragen worden
hättest dann irgendwas besser oder
schlechter gemacht nein es werden
brennende autos gewesen also extremismus
als solcher darf wenn wir uns nach
einigen ist
nein darauf an das ist das was leute wie
sie wollen sich immer darauf einigen wir
lehnen jede form von extremismus
gleichermaßen ab
das ist eine verharmlosung der situation
wir haben ein recht terroristisches
problem mehr einholen kann man deshalb
muss ich mich jetzt mit linksextremismus
moment einfach gerade mal gar nicht
beschäftigen ja aber es wird ihnen nicht
gelingen aus einem manifesten problem
mit rechtsextremismus weil sie den
linken komplett auszublenden
nein findet man das muss man hier
austragen hallo
[Musik]